you revealed earlier this year that you
are going through
some health struggles how is your health
today i'm just like on a wave
and a lot of ups and downs and um
different forms of pains and
i've probably seen a couple different
doctors gotta go do a good old
colonoscopy tomorrow so
tell the world out daughtered
season eight we're in the middle of
things right now
what has the reaction from fans been so
far the fans are loving how
you know the girls personalities are
shining we've laughed probably more than
ever watching the episodes and so i
think this season's been a good one
we've highlighted multiple kids in the
episodes and gone back and like looked
at old footage and like highlighted
their personalities and stuff and
those are our favorite episodes because
like you know they're just so nostalgic
for us and stuff and
you know just to go back and just like
relive those memories it's been awesome
what is the reaction to for you guys
seeing yourselves on air and reliving a
lot of these moments and how do the
girls react
to you know seeing this like time
capsule of their lives playing out
i mean for us for us it's like just
really surreal
honestly my kids are sitting down on the
couch watching themselves
on tv you know and that's crazy
yeah i mean it's crazy and um but it's
also been
the last five six years of our life with
being parents of six kids
we have had a tv show and so it's kind
of just accustomed
to like this is what we do and this is
you know our days and uh we
see ourselves on tv so it feels just
very normal if that's even a word too
but the girls i think that's one of my
favorite things is
the girl's reactions to what they see
caught on camera you know when they were
babies and they see all the poop stuff
like they they absolutely love that kind
of stuff
any form of messes um or the
sister fights you know and i think i
have a picture of ava just sitting on
the coffee table just staring at herself
laughing because like wait what that's
me it was funny
we got to see hazel and graham
i know i feel like they need it like a
couple's name i think we're going with
grazel now
[Laughter]
who's graham my boyfriend what do you
guys make of this
you know hazel has always been our boy
crazy one since
she was probably two years old like it's
just funny and
she is our most sweetest innocent free
spirit
one but man she's boy crazy
what's so funny is like every time he
comes around every time he gets around
us it's like hazel doesn't want to have
anything to do with them it's it's
getting weird to keep saying hazel's
boyfriend i'm like we got to start just
like she's five we're still a ways away
but have the two of you started to
process the idea
of of someday these girls will grow up
and start dating
i don't even want to answer that
question because i don't even want to
think about having to answer
i'll just say we're going to have to
make some type of role you're not
allowed to
date until after high school
yeah look we're not gonna have to worry
about this until like
high school honestly we don't want to
talk about puberty and dayton
yeah i think you got a few years there
are there any like hard and fast busby
rules that that you really want to
instill in your kids or make sure that
they abide by so they go into adulthood
you know prepared for success
we just we really want to raise like
caring loving and compassionate
kids and we have a heart for people and
helping people and stuff like that and
we want to
you know pass that on to our kids and
honestly that's like the most important
thing to us
it's like them loving other people and
caring for other people
and you know and yeah i mean they're on
tv and stuff like that and like
we don't really like i mean we live a
small
life and like we don't literally let
that get to their heads and stuff and
like
you know and we try to keep things as
simple as possible for them how do you
keep the girls
grounded especially as they get older
and you know people at school and their
friends will start to notice oh hey
you're on
television you know how do you guys
navigate all of that there's people
that they watch like on tv and jojo or
like whatever and
you know we'll tell them like they are
real people and we have met some of
those real people
and it's hard for them to kind of
correlate like wait that's you on tv but
that's you in real life and so we try to
just keep them super grounded
of like you know people do know you even
though you don't know who they are
and you know at school is one of those
probably most common areas that they see
oh i see you on tv
and our girls are just kind of like they
still think it's weird they just think
it's weird they're like
yeah i mean don't don't you see yourself
on tv
that's what they think you know you know
i want to talk about how the show
out daughtered it's just so positive so
what is it like being a part of this
reality television landscape
where you're you're putting out you know
a very positive piece of content into
the world
i think that we just really have worked
hard to say like let's
have this show be joyful and we want to
make people laugh and want to
we want to be real and we want to be us
which we are
um but we just don't really care for a
lot of drama
we've shared the bad with the good
throughout our show i mean yeah
fortunately like it's mostly been good
and it's both mostly been happy and fun
moments
but then there's also danielle's like
health struggles like we don't have all
the answers and we haven't
really gotten to you know a solution of
like
what's even going on you know whenever i
went through depression
and stuff and just being open and
sharing that with other people
and it it helped a lot of people i
commend the both of you for being
so open and so candid about you know the
not so fun things in life
and danielle especially right now i just
want to
give you a piece of my heart and let you
know that you are sincerely in my
prayers
i know that you revealed earlier this
year that you are going through
some health struggles i'm curious how is
your health today
thank you for that um appreciate the
prayers for sure um
i i i would i'm just like on a wave
and a lot of ups and downs and um
different forms of pains and
um from physical pains to um
migraines to numbness to tinglings to
digestive problems to a little bit of
skin issues so
it's just it is a bunch of random things
that are just kind of
you know going through hills and valleys
trying to learn what do i need to do
differently and how do i do differently
and how can we help
and what's the route and what's the root
cause of it i have been feeling a little
off lately but
i don't really want to think about that
because i just want to have a good time
i don't know if you read youtube
comments ever but a lot of fans
are leaving comments with their best
thoughts predictions you know wisdom
from things that they've experienced in
the past
do you ever see those things and do you
have any guesses about what your
diagnosis could be
occasionally i will choose to
kind of look um because i can say that
um some things have been eye-opening for
someone saying oh i've had that same
struggle
in this and so i was like okay so let me
ask my doctor about that
i'm thankful for all the comments and
the prayers for sure um i
try my best to um read and to
try to comment um on what i can it is a
full-time schedule just trying to
keep going to all these doctors and
everything and so just kind of putting
my trust in
you know letting the medical profession
help me but i love all advice from
other moms or other people who have gone
through some similar issues
what are the next steps
um i've had a couple different
procedures
um and like tons of tests and everything
done
over the last probably five six months
but um
there really is no identifying
conclusion to this looking at possible
autoimmune disease and so
sometimes that's just not easily defined
i'm just trying to really you know look
into foods and like how do i eat
differently could that help with
inflammation and because there are
certain foods that you know
underline with inflammation and
everything and so it's really how do we
maintain your pain
level and what you're going through
until we can discover what the
underlying issue is
well you sound like you are doing all
the right things i am so
um hopeful that you will find the
conclusion i do want to ask you danielle
you know not only your physical health
your mental health um how is that doing
today
i just really look into my spirituality
to just kind of help you know
keep my mental state you know aligned
because you know it can
it can it can go off in waves you can
get stressed out real easily in this
house and
so you know i think just with you know
fitness which is always a
mental blocker for me where i can just
zone out and stuff and so
that's always something i you know try
to keep on top of and then just my
spirituality
it could be something else too
like what do you mean i don't know
there's like days that they'll be fine
but then there's like days that it's
like
painful at times and i feel like i've
always been able to like handle it
and like manage it but i feel
weird all of a sudden i just feel like
off
but you don't know why
i don't know maybe they just need a time
to refuel and like replenish
does blake know about this do the quints
know about this
they do um to an extent
i mean i had an episode which took me to
the emergency room
it's hard for them to understand what
i'm doing but they still know i got a
doctor's appointment i'm going here i
got to do this test and
um so they they they know they just
don't really understand like
what the struggle is yeah adam um i want
to know as a supportive partner
what has this experience been like for
you i mean it's it
it's honestly been tough through this
process of just like you know seeing her
frustrated just because like we don't
really know what's going on and
you know just trying to support her
through the process and
you know and encourage her you know as
best i can but also just like trying to
take as much of the weight
and burden of just like the everyday
like
you know task around the house and
parenting and stuff so that she can kind
of like relax a little bit either have a
day to just like
do what she wants to do or just like
relax like in bed you know if it's a day
that like she's just hurting
um and then just like just supporting
her whenever i can
we've seen eight seasons about
daughtered
how much longer do you see this show
going for
we just go season by season to kind of
adjust and say like what do we need to
do differently and
you know do we want to continue and yeah
and i mean after after every season it's
like a big
like life evaluation you know
at the end of the season it's just like
you know like
what's this gonna look like moving
forward and so yeah what's next i mean
we're not 100 sure yet well we love
following your journey you've got
six incredible beautiful young women is
the busby family complete
i mean physically yes i mean i had a
hysterectomy two like a year and a half
ago so
there's there's there's no more but you
know
if we ever want a little boy around we
just go grab those two little nephews of
ours
and then we have them for a day and
we're like that's enough yeah
and we've always said that i mean we'd
never fully close a door on like an
adoption if like something came on you
know our way and like pressed on our
heart that like we needed to like
help um we never closed the door on that
you're a beautiful family a beautiful
couple and danielle please let us know
if we can ever do anything to help
support you on your journey
thank you so much
you